[Music]
in rap rat News submitted by Greg from
Montreal hey Greg rapper Takashi's 69
has finally been sentenced in his
racketeering case oh my god I loved all
the memes about him he was riding so
hard he became a meme because he was
such a bad boy but he just kept ratting
as soon as he could well a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he looks like a [ __ ] clown
my thing is I have no sympathy for him
or his fans it is time I'm just saying
the fans are just as dumb oh yeah like
you you propped this guy up and like you
know you told most I was cool yeah you
told him he was like he was so cool it's
like this shows you how fleeting this
like the societal like entered the
entertainment and popularity really it
is what's craziest the younger
generation thinks he's hard that people
that look like him but he just looks
like someone that slept over at like a
frat house we after everyone drew on him
and dyed his hair all [ __ ] done his
hair looks like a snow cone
face tattoos I just I'm out there's a
lot of high school kids with face
tattoos and crazy hair like that's the
look now it's like you don't so you
don't ever want to work yeah you know so
you can you you could be a rapper or
what you know what I mean you can work
in a auto shop basically even even then
but I think their goal is to have a job
it's probably to sell drugs exactly
maybe a bad boy what's gonna happen when
they legalized drug true oh my god
that's why they should they should
legalize drugs just to get rid of face
tattoos just I want people business
suits selling heroin then you like
manage the guy I'm here to sell drugs
like man and I we need somebody that's
more corporate looking friendly yeah
it's gonna be like enterprise a rental
car you have to have a tire we bring the
drugs to you [ __ ] Aaron Eckhart in the
suit so Alan
alright guys so the story here with
Takashi 69 so he was originally facing
47 a minimum of 47 years in prison when
this whole racketeering thing but then
he decided to sing like a canary and
just really just tell the feds
everything which led to them convicting
two more people of his own game so
what's the sentence reduction yeah two
years literally got sentenced to two
years oh my god I would do the same [ __ ]
boy five years I've not gotten every
[ __ ] keep in mind he's already
served 13 months so he's gonna be out in
like late next year yeah but the funny
thing is this is not even street cred
though so he's gonna come out and start
rapping it's like you didn't yeah let me
tell you let me tell you okay so all
these charges right all the [ __ ] that he
he said they're looking into the fact
that he is going to go into the witness
protection program
after he gets out because there's
literally a hit out first how is he
gonna change his identity with the way
he looks it's gonna be a challenge
because of his face tattoos maybe can I
hide from attention he's gonna continue
wanting to make music and all that [ __ ]
you should honor to me to me he should
first of all he's not Takashi anymore
he's Fernando yeah they with Daniel
Daniel friendly yeah so when you know
his name is Daniel Hernandez yeah you're
not talking yeah yeah you're Daniel
Hernandez yeah it's all gone now right
the only thing he could do
professionally probably is stand on a
Hollywood Highland in a spider-man
costume to me should own it to me should
only his next album should be good no no
no he should only should just that's
funny I like that from witness
protection where he is you know he never
recording studio in his suburb house
he's a gardener in the area you know
what I'm saying you're thinking like a
comic though he's takes himself very
seriously I know but he should take
himself seriously about being like I
read a John y'all you know whatever
just own it you know let me so okay so
he did write this letter um where he was
expressing his remorse for his actions
and this is what he said I am NOT a
victim I put myself in this position
from day one I made a lot of bad choices
in life but that doesn't make me a bad
person I'm happy that the public was
able to witness me dealing with the
consequences of my actions because I
feel like it sheds a light on what can
come from gang affiliation the lawyer
did a great job right it doesn't sound
like he wrote it at all I wish it had
arm in it and like yeah so like it
should just have a bunch of arms and all
like stupid about this I just just got
what what did people learn from it the
actions so he was rich he had money for
lawyers
he had 47 years sentenced down to two
years he's about to get out and still
got money in the bank like you think
people are the did he really do anything
for kids at home to be like I don't want
to be like him nope not at all that's
such [ __ ] this guy's full of [ __ ] if
they had a picture of him having a suck
off of inmate before and after yeah he
doesn't even have to wipe when he takes
a [ __ ] that's just it's just a splash I
like a roll oh yeah this is just this is
nonsense right here this is all he got a
one point for his conviction for using a
minor in a sexual performance in a music
video and then he got two more points
for his involvement in the ninth ray
Bloods gang while he was on probation
and so with those three points it puts
him in a category to which the highest /
worst criminal history rating is a six
so that's the reason why he was facing a
minimum of forty seven years in prison
did you have to register as a sex
offender - I don't know about that
probably does
well maybe not if he's in a witness
protection program thing because then he
can't registers oh that's the way that's
the way to get out of his face registers
as a couple of things just because of
the tats I think yeah he pled guilty for
multiple counts of racketeering
conspiracy firearms
it's a narcotics trafficking because he
was involved with dealing heroin and all
ecstasy and fin memes and weed is he
going into witness protection do they
say that are you actually gonna do that
it looks like that's the route that's
gonna happen because even as of right
now they oh so the reason why he got
arrested in the first place was because
he went on The Breakfast Club that radio
show and he was pretty much saying that
his like fellow gang members members
turn their back on him and then that's
when the feds are like oh [ __ ] he's
about to go like to a casino or
something and by him being in public
like that it puts the rest of the public
in danger because now his gang is gonna
try to kill him and that's the reason
why he got arrested and then that's when
he ended up telling the feds everything
detection unless somebody believed in
the hype man please just believe in the
hype about himself and it just is all
taken away I like how the feds are
listening to The Breakfast Club to you
listen to podcasts yeah on their commute
probably sure like Oh what somebody was
just at their desk with the headphones
on like oh [ __ ] yeah they were
investigating everything he was doing
everything he was involved when involved
in and so he also admitted to there's
also this video of him offering a thirty
thousand dollar bounty for someone to
shoot chief keeps cousin because he was
there's this video that TMZ got where he
was back from back in May last year
where he was facetiming I think is Chief
Keef or his cousin and later on about
three days later that's when someone
opened fire Don Keith and his cousin in
June of 2018 in Times Square away okay
okay here's my problem here's my problem
he he's a rat snitch and everyone around
him is too if I'm facetiming you saying
like we need to kill somebody and you're
recording that people are like that man
yeah like come on is there anything
sacred I can't put out a hit without
somebody not his group obviously his
group is terrible he need to find a new
set of friends that are loyal yeah so
his baby mama her name is Sarah
yeah so she said that for a whole year
he has not cared to hear anything about
their four-year-old daughter and that he
had like water rat his lawyers have been
using their daughter as a prop and so
the mom is like he didn't [ __ ] learn
anything he's not a changed man like he
he's just using our daughter do you
think his mom was like Takashi's 69 I
can't believe you wait first of all
first of all this girl sounds so dumb
when she met him he had face tattoos
what did you expect yeah you that you
liked his fine young man you just guys
put a baby in you and you thought he was
gonna be all of a sudden be father of
the year right I wonder what the dads
into I can't imagine
pretty sure the dad wasn't around at the
front door Oh true yeah like it wasn't
like she was like altered like you know
he was like he lied to her like yeah I
work in I work in a Miss rental car baby
and then at night he goes out with he
puts the face tattoos on and all right
even know Daniel you gotta know the job
is dangerous when you take it that's
like young girls though right that are
in that crowd what people innocent man
money and all that kind of stuff and
Fame and all that it's important you
know I think like the whole like in the
game world like how girls just find that
very attractive yeah you've all had a
bad-boy phase right and then you settle
are you right oh my god she's gonna be
my she's gonna lie to your kids you know
I mean I was I was I never did I left
the nunnery
I left the
convent where your when I was planning
on it but then I realized I made all
these videos on my life I can't lie
anymore [ __ ] okay right here yes you
know we want to know about your stripper
days just with a bad boy right here man
this guy's a bad boy bad boys don't do
podcasts okay boys aren't like you know
setting up cameras or like amber you
know you didn't want a Starbucks order
you know it's not you know the bad boys
like he's like it is brought to you by
audios with audio boom yeah sitting
there with this game podcast they don't
monetize you know I mean they should
they should take is amazing that these
people have these skills these like like
intense business skills guys obviously
he made it you know he's he's artistic
and he and that energy wasn't focused
into something positive you know it just
tells you that like Bill Gates he could
have been like [ __ ] traveling you
know I mean he could have been a drug
lord or what he did you know but he's
not rejected on maybe he would have he
probably thinks he's jacked right now I
don't think his wife cares
maybe he pays everywhere I'm gonna be
like bill looking [ __ ] ripped today
like hey my girl don't care
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]